[Music]
are you okay
she said she was feeling better we see
that regularly with schizophrenia
but it can't be cured
[Music]
okay hanging in there
honey your father's gonna take the door
off the hinges if you keep blocking it
did you hear that there was a girl next
door screaming for help
ryan there's nobody out here there's a
little girl in your attic i saw her
there's no one up there she's lying
you're telling me that your neighbor
kidnapped a little girl and has her
chained in her attic
i just need you to trust me i do all
right
there's no one up there your mind is
just playing tricks on you
please stay away from that house this is
a serious accusation one that will
likely have equally serious consequences
[Music]
hell right he said she works monday
through friday we've been helpful to
mention it was at our school
get it together
it's not real there's no one up there my
mind is just playing tricks
[Music]
i don't care what if it was me i'm not
just gonna sit here
your mind is just playing tricks on you
[Music]
you